I'd have to ask you though I mean even
on Instagram when you were single you're
getting criticized over the recipes
you're okay right now now it's I know
it's real life though we have another
another person to worry about so how's
that
it does seem all silly no like anything
that you've got frustrated by before it
just nothing really matters anymore and
I think you just tend to just things you
just let them go a little bit more it is
hard when it turns to like when it's
when people are grading you on your
personal decisions or you know you'll
just you just realize you'll never make
everybody happy
there's fifty percent of the world is
gonna be mad if you do it one way or
another way so yeah I think I'm just I'm
learning to let things roll off my back
a lot easier and it's gonna have more
important things I don't know yeah yeah
sure you look at the things in the past
and think I know what that wasn't silly
no it's ridiculous how is John handle
that because I've read somewhere that he
said he would love to be able to split
the critic in half and half I take half
of the criticism off you he thinks it's
funny that I even read anything
he's like honestly we will talk about
things over dinner and be like I've had
in trouble again for something he's I
think at this point he just thinks it's
so silly that I even put any steak into
what anyone says online all because I
realized sometimes I'm like reading so
many great comments and so much
positivity and then I stop when I get to
the really horrible one and I'm like it
was almost like I was looking for the
bad one I don't know why I was like that
so I think now I'm just I'm just gonna
stop that and I'm just
you